I'm gonna be spending an entire day
living like a clicker from HBO is The
Last of Us
to do this I made a costume and tried my
best to immerse myself in the life of a
clicker
it was actually pretty easy to make and
it only cost about 20 bucks I started
out with a plastic Halloween mask that
already looks terrifying and I duct
taped some cardboard to the top to act
as a base for the mask then I went
outside to spray some foam under the
mask because apparently the foam is
toxic and it might cause lung damage or
even kill me but anyways it looked
pretty good so then I went back inside
to get to carving this part actually
took quite a bit of time because I
really wanted it to look as much like a
clicker as possible but once I finished
that I got to painting and after about
four coats of paint it was time for the
finishing touches last but not least I
cut a set of zombie teeth in half and
glued them to the bottom of the Mask so
it would look just like a clicker that's
had its entire skull split in two and
now for the finished product
oh I definitely can't see